und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend beginnen wir mit wladimir putin
der zeigt dass russland liefert während
andere reden und fragwürdige sanktionen
verhängen weil russland sich die
ukrainische halbinsel krim angeeignet
hat wohl wieder rechtlich aber am ende
wird es da nicht um juristische finessen
gehen sondern um macht da gilt es fakten
zu setzen und den menschen der krim zu
zeigen dass sie besser dran sind mit
putins stramm durch regierten russland
als mit dieser wackligen regierung der
ukraine und ihrer mehr oder weniger
zuverlässigen freunden in den usa und
der eu für dieses versprechen steht nun
auch eine brücke riesig eine neue
landverbindung zwischen der krim und den
größten land der erde
sie verändert auch die politische
landkarte vilbel gab berichtet dass
vieles aber doch nicht ganz alles glatt
läuft mit putin auf engstem raum im
führerstand einer lok transportminister
dietrich hat diese chance genutzt um den
präsidenten aufmerksam zu machen auf das
was noch fehlt an der bahnstrecke auf
die krim unter anderem bei djankow hier
ist die strecke noch nicht
elektrifiziert man fahre noch mit
dieselloks und das beim prestige projekt
krämpfe der minister aus das müsse
dringend geändert werden
was kostet das fragt der russische
präsident bevor der transportminister
ins detail gehen kann wird putin aus der
situation erlöst da hast du wohl zu viel
geredet bemerkt einer musterung unsere
stundenlang berichtet das russische
staatsfernsehen live von der einweihung
der eisenbahnbrücke sie verbindet
russland mit der annektierten halbinsel
krim verläuft parallel zu der im mai
2008 10 eröffneten autostrecke und ist
19 kilometer lang
stufe ihrer arbeit ihrem können und
ihrem durchhaltevermögen haben sie
gezeigt dass russland in der lage ist
solch ein infrastrukturprojekt der
weltklasse zu verletzen
der applaus wird leicht verhalten dass
präsident putin die ukrainische
halbinsel an russland angeschlossen hat
steigerte 2014 seiner beliebtheit beim
eigenen volk doch mittlerweile scheint
dieser patriotische effekt verpufft
die epoche der krim begeisterung ist
vorbei die leute haben angefangen
nachzuzählen was sie im geldbeutel haben
und das ergebnis ist traurig deswegen
schwindet putins popularität und die der
regierungspartei als antwort darauf üben
die machthaber mehr druck auf die
gesellschaft aus seit baubeginn
erschwert die brücke ukrainischen helfen
die arbeit
sie ist 35 meter hoch größere schiffe
passen nicht darunter durch die häfen
von odessa und mario pohl melden dass
der schiffsverkehr bei ihnen deswegen um
ein viertel zurückgegangen sei die
brücke ist russlands beton gewordener
besitzanspruch auf ukrainisches
territorium nach der krim aktion war die
internationale entrüstung groß
die sanktionen sind noch in kraft
gleichzeitig denkt der nato-chef nun
laut über ein treffen mit putin ab und
der war anfang dezember zu gast im
élysee palast
das treffen im normandie format war eine
chance für putin als gleichberechtigtes
mitglied in die reihen der europäer
zurück zu kehren ohne deswegen die krim
aufgeben wer dabei hilft darf auf das
präsidiale zu hoffen bei der
jungfernfahrt mit an bord arkadi
rotenberg dessen firma die grünbrücke
für 3,3 milliarden euro aufgebaut hat
ich weiß noch wie mich das oberhaupt
einer familie mit dem einfachen
russischen namens rothenberg eines
nachts anrief mit einer stimme dass ich
ihn fragte bist du betrunken
komm schon antwortet rothenberg szenen
einer männerfreundschaft und zeugnis
allerbester geschäftsbeziehungen
allerdings themenwechsel seit einem
interview des grünen-vorsitzenden habeck
der keine regierungsverantwortung trägt
bringen
diejenigen die solche verantwortung
tragen um eine antwort darauf die nicht
unmenschlich klingt aber die grenzen
grundsätzlich geschlossen hält robert
habeck hat auf die elenden zustände in
völlig überfüllten flüchtlingslager auf
den griechischen inseln hingewiesen und
verlangt dass man wenigstens die kinder
dort rausholt viele kommunen und einige
ministerpräsidenten bieten kontingente
für so eine maßnahme an
die bundesregierung versucht diesen
humanitären eifer zu bremsen
migrationspolitik ist bundessache tönte
es aus berlin
annette hilsenbeck berichtet aus dem
lager maria auf lesbos in sichtweite der
türkei und aus der kommen signale die
europa alarmierend und wohl auch
alarmieren sonnen eine behelfsmäßige
bäckerei im flüchtlingslager moria die
hier hausen warten schon monatelang ob
sie asyl bekommen oder nicht und haben
sich damit eingerichtet
muss er ihn ist vor zwei wochen mit
seiner familie gekommen
sie müssen ganz außenanlage rand in
olivenhainen leben in einem billigen
campingzelt hier drin ist es nicht nur
sehr kalt wenn es regnet tropft es auch
rein in den ersten drei tagen nach dem
wir angekommen sind hat es geregnet und
wir hatten noch keine paletten unter dem
zelt da wurden wir von oben
und unten las er war schon einmal in
griechenland wurde abgeschoben jetzt hat
er es wieder gewagt mit seiner familie
wir haben es drei vier mal probiert im
sommer da hat die türkische küstenwache
uns jedes mal gestoppt und
zurückgeschickt aber als wir jetzt im
dezember gekommen sind war keiner da
viele hier berichten dass auch die
griechischen behörden sagen die
türkische küstenwache lasse
flüchtlingsboote ungehindert passieren
ein klarer bruch des eu türkei deals in
diesem jahr sind bis mitte dezember laut
un hcr fast 57.000 menschen aus der
türkei auf die griechischen inseln
gekommen drei viertel mehr als 2008 10
ich denke mit den flüchtlingen in der
ägäis wird momentan ein geopolitisches
spiel gespielt
auf der türkischen seite haben wir den
präsidenten erdogan der diese migranten
als soldaten für seine zwecke einsetzt
und nach griechenland und damit nach
europa schickt im lager einst für 3600
menschen gedacht leben jetzt über 18.000
viele kinder über ein drittel der
migranten ist jünger als 17 jahre
die griechischen behörden überfordert
mit der situation nicht regierungs
organisationen unterstützen sie
befestigen die wege mit kies schaffen
eine stromversorgung doch das lager
wächst viel zu schnell stürmen sind
einfach sehr viele bereiche im camp in
einem schrecklichen zustand die leute
leben immer noch in dünnen zelten die
für den sommer gemacht sind
wir versuchen die mit geeignetem zelten
zu ersetzen
das alles sind nur provisorische
lösungen um menschenwürdige zustände zu
schaffen dass die menschen monate sogar
jahre auf ihren asylbescheid warten
damit soll schluss sein
die griechische regierung hat
angekündigt die verfahren endlich zu
beschleunigen
hussein und seine familie haben ihren
anhörungstermin schon im januar
da war ein aspekt in annettes bericht
der nach haken verlangt ich meine
übereinstimmenden aussagen von
flüchtlingen
und des bürgermeisters nach denen die
türkei plötzlich ihre seegrenze zu
griechenland nicht mehr richtig bewacht
halim hosny ist für uns in istanbul
der bürgermeister sprach von einem spiel
der mächtigen mit den flüchtlingen was
wird da gespielt
also ich denke dass die äußerungen von
erdogan gestern eher innenpolitisch
motiviert waren und sich eher gegen das
eigene volk gewandt haben denn erdogan
hat eine große ein großes problem hier
in der türkei eine tiefe
wirtschaftskrise die schon lange
andauert natürlich auch hausgemacht
durch die politik die er in den
vergangenen jahren getrieben hat und die
folge ist natürlich gravierend hohe
arbeitslosigkeit auch die türkische lira
hat erheblich an wert verloren also sind
nicht sehr große unruhe hier im land und
dazu kommt auch noch das ehemalige
weggefährten erdogan sich jetzt
abgesetzt haben der ehemalige
außenminister babacan hat gerade eine
neue partei gegründet der ehemalige
ministerpräsident david otto wird im
januar wohl eine neue partei gründen und
gerade hat sich hier in istanbul mit
leckeren immer nur ein bürgermeister der
jungen garde sozusagen bereit gemacht
mit ganz großem charisma er setzt auf
von politik der demokratie ersetzt auf
eine bürgerbeteiligung und transparenz
all das was als gegenentwurf sozusagen
zu erdogan steht das sind also dinge die
auf den türkischen staatspräsidenten zu
kommen die ihm sicherlich große probleme
bereiten wenn man jetzt aus europa auf
die lage blickt politisch dann mit angst
in den augen dass die türkei wieder
tausende oder zehntausende menschen über
das meer nach gießen griechenland lässt
wird das so kommen
es ist durchaus vorstellbar dass noch
mehr kommen werden als bisher denn die
türkei versucht ja viele flüchtlinge
wieder zurück in die sogenannte sichere
zone in nordsyrien zu transportieren und
es gibt sehr viele syrer hier die das
auf keinen fall wollen und dann doch
lieber den weg suchen über das wasser
richtung europa darauf hört man sich
einstellen müssen dankeschön halim hosny
hier geht es weiter den nachrichten von
gundula gause über den abbau der hohen
schulden vieler kommunen gibt es eine
kontroverse diskussion kritik an
entsprechenden plänen von finanzminister
scholz kommt von mehreren bundesländern
die selbst bereits viel geld in ihre
überschuldeten kommunen gesteckt haben
die hessen bremen oder niedersachsen
über 2000 städte und gemeinden vor allem
in nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz
und dem saarland haben besonders hohe
altschulden insgesamt geschätzt über 40
milliarden euro für sie wollen bund und
länder anfang des neuen jahres eine
lösung finden
mehr menschen als von der
bundesregierung angenommen gehen
abschlagsfrei mit 63 in rente seit juli
2014 haben insgesamt rund 1,34 millionen
senioren die 45 beitragsjahre vorweisen
können
diese entscheidung gefällt nach
berechnungen des arbeitsministeriums
sollten es etwa eine million sein
die zahl der straftaten gegen politiker
bleibt auf hohem niveau
laut bundesinnenministerium wurden am
häufigsten politiker von cdu und fdp
angegriffen
insgesamt waren in diesem jahr 1241 amts
und mandatsträger opfer von politisch
motivierte gewalt 15 weniger als im
vorjahr rechtsextreme verübten davon 440
linksextreme 246 straftaten in mehr als
500 fällen konnte das motiv nicht
festgestellt werden
über ein jahr nach dem mord an der
regierungskritischen journalistin kvg
hat ein gericht in saudi arabien fünf
menschen zum tode verurteilt ein
spezialkommando aus riad hatte karrubi
brutal getötet in der saudischen
botschaft in istanbul mehrere
geheimdienste sehen hinweise darauf dass
der auftrag dazu möglicherweise von
kronprinz salman kam was dieser
bestreitet
in frankreich gehen die streiks gegen
die rentenreform weiter schon den neun
zehnten tag in folge und es soll weiter
gestreikt werden
auch über weihnachten der bahnverkehr
bleibt landesweiten massiv gestört metro
und regionalzüge fahren kaum auch mehr
als die hälfte aller schnellzüge fiel
heute wieder aus präsident makro
appellierte an die gewerkschaften den
betrieb über die feiertage aufrecht zu
erhalten
die gewerkschaften lehnen das jedoch ab
die segnungen der digitalen revolution
werden ihren preis haben und der wird
hoch sein
in einer zeit in der jeder das wissen
der menschheit in der hand hält müssen
jahrtausendealte vorratsspeicher von
wissen mit als erste unter die räder
kommen
wir brauchten noch bibliotheken mit
fernleihe systemen sollte man meinen
man würde sich irren es gibt einen
morgen für bibliotheken nicht für die
die einfach weiter bestand in den
letzten zehn jahren wurden in
deutschland anderthalbtausend
geschlossen aber knapp 9000 gibt es noch
und die die sich neues einfallen lassen
haben eine chance berichtet dort der
färber unterhalten und lernen horizonte
erweitern nach überraschungen schauen
das hat auch etwas mit dem zu tun was
zwischen menschen passieren
nach der schule ist lesezeit moorriem
hat der riedenberger lockt der
sechsjährige wollte rein in diese
bibliothek irgendwann ist man mit mama
hin zum bären jetzt kommen sie ständig
ich habe meinen sohn von der schule
abgeholt und dann hierher gekommen
bekommen jeden tag hin verlesen abbas
zusammen
ja und er spielt hier gerne um eine art
öffentliches wohnzimmer
seit dem umbau ist dass die bibliothek
in köln-kalk einem stadtteil in dem 75
prozent der jugendlichen einen
migrationshintergrund haben
sie kommen jetzt gerne es gibt wlan
es gibt freunde es gibt ruhe man kann
hausaufgaben machen
chillen oder auch zocken bibliotheken
sind nicht nur ein ort der bildung
sondern auch ein teil der sozialen
infrastruktur einer stadt jedermann kann
kommen es ist konsens frei für viele
menschen gerade auch für ältere die
vielleicht eins haben sind ist es ein
ort wo man hingehen kann
40 prozent mehr besucher haben sie seit
dem umbau auch dank längerer
öffnungszeiten
man kann auch dann rein wenn das
personal schon feierabend hat und das
bibliotheks mobil fährt raus zu den
leuten so sind neue junge nutzer
gekommen und die älteren sind geblieben
also hier jesus lauter als zb in der
zentralbibliothek am neumarkt weil hier
auch viele jugendliche sind kinder auch
manchmal muss man auch von draußen der
ordnungsdienst reinkommen und also hier
ist deutlich lautet ist aber stört mich
nicht
mindestens zweimal pro woche kommen sie
her bahn und die anderen aus der
spieletester gruppe in köln kalk haben
sie stadtweit die meisten elektronischen
spiele
sie testen neue für einen elternratgeber
ich finde es auch nicht so der bücher
fan weil ich mag eben mehr das digitale
ich finde eben jetzt nicht dass bücher
konzert besser und ich komme auch
eigentlich ziemlich viel testen und
spielen
dutzende workshops bietet die bibliothek
vom programmieren der riesigen lichtwand
mit dem ipad bis hin zum 3d druck tüftel
statt büffeln heißt es dazu gibt es auch
medienpädagogen und vor allem gibt es
eine neue idee die bibliothek ist auch
wie man ort um sich zu treffen um sich
auszutauschen und eben auch ein ort des
wissens sozusagen und dem man lernen
kann und das kann man eben auch nicht
nur mit medien sondern eben auch in dem
man zusammen gemeinsam etwas lernt
lernen lesen und leben in köln-kalk
finden alle ihr plätzchen eine
erfolgreiche bibliothek im digitalen
zeitalter
weit mehr als die welt der bücher
apropos nachhaltigkeit es fehlt nicht
mehr an bewusstsein dafür wie wichtig
das ist aber damit ist ja noch keine
lösung gefunden kleidung zb wenn zur
mitte dieses jahrhunderts also bald dann
zehn milliarden menschen kleidung
brauchen und dabei auch höhere ansprüche
daran stellen woher soll das material
dafür kommen kunststoffe plastik
verbrauchen öl als rohstoff und als
energiequelle baumwollproduktion sieht
erstmal umweltfreundlicher aus erfordert
aber unmengen von wasser in finnland dem
land großer wälder sind forscher darauf
gekommen dass man mit hightech aus dem
ältesten werkstoff überhaupt
hochinteressante fasern
gewinnen kann sie sind sogar kleidsam
heike kruse berichtet wie 80 cm
birkenstamm für ein abendkleid die robe
von jenny haug io der frau des
finnischen präsidenten besteht aus einer
neuartigen phase dafür wird zum beispiel
aus holz nachwachsender wälder zellstoff
zellulose gewonnen und die zu der neuen
textilfaser verarbeitet professoren und
studenten der universitäten von helsinki
und espoo haben das verfahren erfunden
und entwickelt für sie ist eins ganz
entscheidend dass ohne dem einsatz von
schädlichen chemikalien aus zell stoffen
aus ein textil abfällen oder auch als
zeitschriften neuer fasern nachhaltige
fasern produziert werden können
und die finden sich einig das thema der
zukunft und der heutigen zeit
nachhaltige mode nennt das
internationale team dann auch stolz
seine zukunftsvision die laborarbeit ist
weder glamourös noch modisch und kein
kinderspiel
zehn jahre hat es gedauert bis zum
sprung in die öffentlichkeit
1 11 der stoff aus dem die zukunft ist
das ist etwas was die welt braucht ich
meine baumwolle herstellung benötigt so
viel wasser die plantagen brauchen so
viel platz diese forschung hier war der
wichtigste grund warum ich teil des
teams werden wollte
meiner meinung nach hätten wir die welt
die alte universität innsbruck alle
fachbereiche versuchen aus
klimafreundlichen visionen realität zu
machen wie wohne ich und verbrauchen nur
wenig energie wie lebe ich und reduziere
meine co2 bilanz über den klimawandel
mut zureden ist hier aber keine option
ich finde jetzt auch nicht sehr
realistisch wenn wir das einfach weiter
gehen lassen und dann zu sehen was dann
die folgen sind von dem von der globalen
erwärmung aber ich denke das ist schon
durchaus realistisch ist natürlich auch
ambitioniert aber es ist natürlich gut
wenn man sich das vornimmt dann kann man
ja auch planen wie es denn geht
und es geht auch aus einer alten jeans
gewinnen die forscher aus espoo mit
ihrem verfahren die neue textilfaser wir
sind noch auf labor niveau aber jetzt
werden wir die produktion nach vorne
bringen und dann schauen ob es noch
probleme gut aber ich glaube das wird
klappen mit der kommerziellen produktion
ob diese beiden modelle mal als rot
couture gelten werden zumindest ein
schal hat es schon aus dem finnischen
labor bis nach paris geschafft die krise
um den boeing flieger 737 max hat
vorstand dennis muilenburg den job
gekostet nach den abstürzen zweier
boeing-maschinen wurde der druck immer
größer
lang hatte marburg aber einen rücktritt
abgelehnt frank bethmann
was gab nun den ausschlag ja es darf
spekuliert werden erst am wochenende
miss langes boeing eine kapsel zur
internationalen raumstation iss zu
befördern statt befreiungs also der
nächste fehlschlag offenbar zu viel für
mannenberg der bullen chef galt seit
wochen als angeschlagen
viel zu lange ließ er die 737 max weiter
fertigen viel zu spät der vorläufigen
produktionsstopp die folge auf dem
werksgelände reitzig maschine an
maschine alle unverkäuflich so lange es
keinen staat erlaubnis gibt die aber
lässt immer noch auf sich warten
mühlenberg wurde mehr und mehr zum
gesicht der krise auch weil der jetzt
geschasste bulligen chef massiv im
streit lag mit dem bus der us
flugaufsichtsbehörde dixon dicksten
fühlte sich zuletzt von ruhigen massiv
unter druck gesetzt und verweigert bis
auf weiteres eben jene staat erlaubnis
jeder tag jede woche aber die die vielen
37 max am boden bleiben verdient bohlen
kein geld mit seinem wichtigsten jet
mehr noch die klagewelle droht immer
größer zu werden
boeing musste also handeln weil eine
lösung des problems mit möllenberg an
der spitze beinahe aussichtslos schien
vielen dank frank bei der lufthansa
drohen neue streiks zwar nicht nur die
feiertage aber direkt danach könnten die
flugbegleiter auch der konzerntöchter
wie euro vinx aufgerufen werden
die arbeit niederzulegen erklärte deren
gewerkschaft ufo
die vorgespräche für eine schlichtung im
tarifkonflikt mit der lufthansa haben
bislang keine fortschritte gebracht
dabei geht es unter anderem um zulagen
und lohn für die 22.000
kabinenmitarbeiter
australiens premier morrison hat die
klimapolitik seiner regierung verteidigt
trotz der anhaltenden waldbrände
er stehe hinter der kohleförderung in
seinem land gleichzeitig räumte er
fehler im umgang mit dem verheerenden
feuern ein morrison steht in der kritik
auch weil er urlaub auf hawaii machte
als die brände immer heftiger wurden
seit oktober haben die buschfeuer
ungefähr drei millionen hektar land und
mehr als 1000 häuser zerstört mindestens
zehn menschen verloren in den feuern ihr
leben
venedig leidet noch immer unter den
folgen des katastrophalen hochwassers im
vergangenen november
und jetzt haben schwere unwetter das
wasser in der lagunenstadt wieder
steigen lassen
weite teile des historischen
stadtzentrums sind erneut überflutet mit
einem höchststand von 1 meter 44 blieb
der pegel jedoch leicht niedriger als
zunächst befürchtet aber wieder müssen
bewohner und touristen stege nutzen oder
durch das wasser waten über neue schäden
ist bislang nichts bekannt
2009 10 ist oder bald kann man sagen war
das ja 30 nach dem fall der berliner
mauer
man darf sich diese nacht des 9 november
89 er nicht als einen historischen
durchbruch vorstellen nachdem dann
schlagartig alles anders wurde das hat
schon noch gedauert
besonders an der innerdeutschen grenze
zwischen brd und ddr blieben die
grenzposten noch wochenlang besetzt und
geschlossen so auch zwischen heinersdorf
in thüringen und vehlitz und neukenroth
in bayern bis tief in den advent und
jetzt ändern sie sich dort an diese ganz
besondere zeit im letzten winter der ddr
johanna kissler aus unserem studio
erfurt berichtet
macht hoch die tür die tor macht weit
wenn die kapelle dieses advent lied
anstimmt bekommen sie im thüringischen
heinersdorf auch nach 30 jahren immer
noch gänsehaut macht hoch die tür hatte
damals für das kleine ddr dorf im
sperrgebiet noch eine zweite eine ganz
handfeste bedeutung öffnet die grenze
die blaskapelle spielte damals ganz
besonders laut
wir haben uns dann schon im vorfeld mit
dem musikverein aus dem nachbarort auf
bayerischer seite verständigt und haben
quasi mit friedlichen mitteln und es
wurden schöne mit der musik die grenze
zum fragen gebracht während einzelne
grenzübergänge am 19 november 1989 schon
geöffnet sind steht hier in der nähe von
sonneberg die mauer noch felsenfest bis
die heinersdorfer initiative ergreifen
brigitte eckert und je mehr ich waren
damals ganz vorne mit dabei wie hier die
bauern und estore da standen die bürger
von franken vom willy zum 30 und hier
wir standen wir mit der blaskapelle und
dann ging es los
immer lauter erklingen protestrufe und
blasmusik auf beiden seiten bis die
grenzsoldaten dem druck schließlich
nachgeben und das verstaubte tor öffnen
nach jahrzehnten der teilung ist der weg
zwischen bayern und thüringen nun auch
an dieser stelle endlich wieder frei 30
jahre später bringt brigitte hat in
ihrem stammtisch zimmer immer noch
menschen zusammen
bei all den misstönen zwischen ost und
west tut die erinnerung an das
gemeinsame ganz gut
diese aufbruchstimmung und man kann es
gar nicht so richtig fassen dass wir
weltgeschichte direkt vor ort erleben
durften die emotionen die haben kurze
bank jeder hat jeden im arm gelegen und
wollen wir noch mehr worden ob ost oder
west das spielt für sie von diesem
zeitpunkt an keine rolle mehr und aus
einer der ersten grenzübergreifenden
begegnungen von damals wurde eine tiefe
freundschaft mit gemeinsamen
erinnerungen wie die an einen
unbeleuchteten weihnachtsbaum den die
freundin damals im grenzbereich entdeckt
hat man ja noch die volkspolizisten hier
gewesen plötzlich kam eine auf mich zum
habe ich mir gedacht okay dann sag dazu
mir ach wissen sie was der baum ist vom
westen und der strom kommt vom osten
ich mache ihnen mal seit diesem kleinen
advents wunder von heinersdorf feiern
sie weihnachten wieder gemeinsam und
glauben hier ganz besonders fest an die
kraft der musik die grenzen überwinden
kann und menschen wieder zusammenbringt
[Musik]
na dann frohe weihnachten wünschen dass
schon heute und heute.de werden weiteres
welt geschehen im auge behalten und
ihnen berichten dass in guten händen
mögen sie und ihre leben ist auch sehr
schöne und friedliche feiern
fussball
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die serie der
tiefe reißt nicht ab und das nächste
wartet schon auf dem ostatlantik oder
erreichte uns morgen im tagesverlauf von
westen her sehen hier in blau den regen
und in weiß den schnee der fällt
allerdings eher in den alpen
schauen wir in die nacht zum star regnet
es in der mitte deutschlands einige
schauer sind hier unterwegs im süden
fällt regen und schnee oberhalb von 900
metern an den alpen
ansonsten liegen die temperaturen bei 1
bis 7 grad
morgen dann am vormittag erreichen und
sie wollten von dem neuen tief im westen
oder es regnet nach osten hin ist es
teilweise freundlich oder auch im süden
zeigt sich mal die sonne zum nachmittag
wird es allerdings deutlich
ungemütlicher
der regen und der schnee wandert weiter
ostwärts und mit schnee müssen sie
oberhalb von 700 metern in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen rechnen
ganz im nordosten ist es trocken und der
wind ist kräftig aus südwest die
temperaturen erreichen 5 grad im
vogtland norden sieben bis acht grad im
westen ist es etwas milder mit zehn elf
teils 13 grad im südwesten deutschlands
die nächsten tage am ersten feiertag
wird es durchwachsen seien mit regen und
schnee oberhalb von 600 metern
allerdings sonst ist es relativ
ungemütlich bei 4 bis 10 grad am zweiten
feiertag wird es ruhiger bei zwei bis
sieben grad
damit wünsche ich ihnen einen schönen
abend und ruhige festtage